(zombie moans)
- Oh my god.
This is weird.
Why do they have zombies in a hospital.
What's up, guys?
Dr. Mike here.
For those of you who don't know,
I am a board-certified
family medicine physician,
but I'm also a gamer part time
and I've been trying to break
into Minecraft for some time.
Luckily I found a buddy
in Logdotzip, AKA Tyler,
to help me out.
He guided me through the process.
I downloaded some hospital maps
and I'm about to give you a review
of how accurate these hospital maps are,
what I would change.
I'm linking them all down below
so the creators can get
your downloads as well.
Let's get started. (makes weird noise)
(zombie growls)
Modern hospitle.
Hospitle.
I'm gonna click "I know what I'm doing".
I'm a physician.
Okay.
I see a sheep.
First of all I want to
come out really far away
and take a look at this hospital,
because this hospital looks
more like a Miami condo
than it does a hospital.
Is this the garden when
patients go to garden?
Oh my god, I've never played this game.
I get hit stuff?
Oh, look at these little seagulls.
Wait, what?
What is this?
They look like little baby eggplants.
What are these?
You think they're fishies?
Wait a second, look at
little positive sign!
That's nice.
Let's take a look at the whips
that they put (whip cracks)
in front of the hospital.
This is kind of a whack car.
This looks like a Hummer circa 1984.
Wait, why are there pigs
in front of the hospital?
Some had way too good of a time.
And then there's bones?
Ooh.
You can pick the stuff up.
Can I get the little piggy?
Come here little piggy,
piggy, piggy, piggy.
Piggy, piggy, piggy.
Wait, I'm trying to ride the piggy.
Piggy, let me ride you.
(gasps) No, don't hit the piggy.
That's a seagull.
Do seagulls attack in this game?
I will say whoever created this,
their gardening in on point.
Oh look, it's a person.
Or is that a security guard?
It's definitely a security
guard 'cause my man's got a bow.
Aye, bow, put that bow down, bro.
All right, sorry, I'm creating
havoc in the hospital.
Let's go.
What is going on here?
This is not a hospital.
What is that?
Why is this thingy like this?
Hi.
And these spiders just
look concerning to me.
There's animals in here.
Is this a veterinary hospital?
Bro is this just,
if someone just designed a hospital
on the exterior that looks really good,
I'll give you props.
But I expect more.
(sheep baas)
I just heard a sheep baa.
Failure of the game number one.
You got to have an elevator in a hospital.
That were all the HIPAA
violations take place.
There's just freaking spiders everywhere.
How are you ever gonna get
better when there's spiders?
Yo, this thing is riding the spider.
It doesn't even care.
This is one unhappy patient.
Why is it green?
Why are you green, buddy?
Okay, I'm going to the top floor.
We're going to the penthouse.
Oh my god,
this person made the
hospital go above the clouds.
Oh, look at these little
ventilators, okay.
The first accurate part of this hospital.
Little AC vent units.
What I would do,
I would confuse people and just say baa.
Now you don't know what it is.
It just looks like a pause logo.
We have to take off all signage
to not confuse people
so they don't think this is a hospital.
'Cause there's no
hospitaling going on here.
I'm giving this hospital,
on an exterior level,
I give it a seven.
It looks beautiful but it
doesn't look like a hospital.
It has balconies.
You don't have balconies on a hospital.
You don't have pools just hanging out here
for patients to swim in.
Interior I give it a zero.
You don't even have an elevator or stairs.
How you gonna get the patients
from one floor to another?
You got to think about this.
I'm starting to get a feel for this
and I'm kind of thinking if I built my own
it'd be a good hospital.
Just saying.
(zombie growls)
Ooh.
This one already is like "come in to me".
This hospital speaks to me.
I probably wouldn't put
the logos like that,
here and here.
That's too much.
Is this for people and
then this is for the birds?
And they got a helicopter pad!
Ooh, if I was a helicopter I'd land here.
(mimics helicopter rotors)
I don't know why I like breaking stuff.
This is a good roof.
This is the proper antennae
that you need for cellular communication.
That kind of looks like a lazer
so that's a little strange.
These need to be on the
roofs of tall buildings
'cause we're so high in the clouds
you don't want an airplane being like,
oh, what is that, oh
my god, (weird noises).
Honestly, outside it's
clean, it's thorough,
but it doesn't have any landscaping.
You know, the landscaping is
gonna cost you some points.
I'm gonna give this
hospital a straight seven.
Just the fact that it doesn't
have any kind of landscaping
except these bouncy bushes,
I don't like it.
What's with the spiders, man?
This one has a spider too!
I'm telling you hospitals
don't have spiders.
All right, let's go
through the main entrance.
There's a seagull.
Oh look, there's employees
with bows and arrows.
You come in here and you say
"Hi, I'm here 'cause I
have a bone that's broken.
"Can you help me?"
You go to the waiting
area and they're like
"Sir, we'll call you when you're ready."
And you're like "Oh my god,
this hospital's so mean."
Whoa.
Oh no.
Oh no!
Dr. Mike fell out of
the world, score four?
Okay, respawn me, I need to do that again.
That was bad.
Is this,
this is a double room.
My god, is this a sink?
This looks like a jail!
(gasps) Is this a jail hospital?
(zombies moaning)
(witch chuckles)
The sound effects in this
game are freaking me out.
(zombies growling and moaning)
Whoa.
Whoa, were was that?
I saw something move.
Is this 'cause I fell out and
they put me into the hospital?
Okay, I need to get out
of here, I'm freaking out.
I'm freaking out!
No!
I've managed to curtail my fall.
(zombie moans)
Oh my god.
This is weird.
Why do they have zombies in a hospital?
And there's bats in here?
They need to fix this place up.
And why are there stairs right here?
Why are there, oh oh,
wait what is that?
Is that bacon?
Rotten flesh, ew!
First of all, why are they jails?
This looks like,
free the patient.
Free the patients!
Now it looks like a hospital.
And let's expand these rooms.
See, now you have a connecting room.
Now people can hang out
together and it's more sociable.
Okay, exterior I said was a seven.
Interior has really disappointed me.
It's not a one.
I'm gonna give the
interior a three out of 10.
So in this one
I'm not gonna take away
their full accreditation,
I'm just gonna take away their L.
So it's a hospita.
And it's raining.
I don't like that, it's raining.
I'm gonna leave now.
(zombie growls)
Ooh, this hospital is very, very cute.
I love the color scheme.
If I was a patient
I would be excited to go to this hospital.
There's a lot of support animals.
There's emotional support sheep,
emotional support bushes.
They didn't even try and make it big.
They were like "This is
a tiny community hospital
"for small doctors like Dr. Mike
"to come in a see what's up."
I love the design.
And again there's spiders.
What's with the zombies and the spiders?
This is the reception.
You come in and again you say
"Hey, I have something
wrong with me, help me.
"Help me."
And the person's like "Do
you even have insurance,"
and I'm like "No, help me.
"I should live in a country
where we are all covered."
Then I realize I was getting political
in a game like Minecraft so
I decided to take the stairs.
So I'm assuming these are exam rooms.
Come on.
They didn't even put patients bed in here?
What is this bench?
What are you supposed to do in bench
besides look at this beautiful view
and the emotional support animals?
There's one more floor.
I hope to be pleasantly surprised.
You're not supposed to have
open flames in a hospital, bro.
Don't you know that oxygen
tanks are flammable?
Put all of these out immediately.
And you want to have curtains up
just in case patients
need a little privacy.
This is ridiculous,
I'm getting frustrated.
And the room just has AC
vents and nothing else.
I'm disappointed.
This hospital gets a four, five,
I think it's cute,
on the outside.
The inside is a solid one
because there's some thought
behind the lighting set up
but I'm taking away
it's medical privilege.
That's it.
No, that kind of still looks
like it has medical privilege.
We got to do this.
Baa, baa.
Okay, now it just looks
like someone's weird home.
Next.
(zombie growls)
Single player.
There's something
addicting about Minecraft
where you don't have to
worry about the real world.
Just build some blocks.
Ooh.
I think this is the psychiatric
hospital that I saw.
Look at the exit, 'cause
you can't walk out.
Baa.
See I like it because you
can't really escape from here.
There's like, you know, barbed wire.
And then I'm not sure
what's going on with here.
This looks rather unfinished, the logo.
I like these little lighting designs.
This looks nice.
This needs to be figured out.
I will say the roof,
the roof is good.
This is a good roof.
You have lights here for planes,
you have this area where you can,
what is this, a cooking area?
Sound alarm if escape is suspected.
Oh, this is the watch tower.
This roof is really looking legit.
I'm liking this roof.
This is a good roof.
I would like for it to have
a helicopter landing pad
in case of a psych emergency.
I can live without it.
Outdoors,
this is a solid seven and a half.
Seven and three quarters.
All right, let's go in.
What does it say here.
"Ambulance Docking Gate-3".
I like these details.
You see, these details are
what make it go a long way.
'Cause if you told me
to pull up to gate G4
I'd be like "Yo, where's gate G4?"
Gate G4 is right here.
"Assessment Unit Whiteforest Max Stay --,"
oh, this is the short term stay.
Yo, this is not bad.
But you need to have a nursing station
'cause I get that these are
little rooms for the patients.
First of all,
don't be a savage.
Give your patients at least
a 10 foot by 10 foot room.
This is not inhabitable.
This one is double doors
so you know this is where
the dangerous people stay.
Someone has a window at least.
Whoever made this
hospital did no recognize
that humans live in psych
wards or stay in psych wards.
So they need room.
They're not like chickens
that need a little hen house.
Let me out!
I feel like I'm a patient.
I'm not about it.
I would like to see my
patients taken care of
better than this.
Is this blood?
Let's get out of here,
I'm creeped out a little bit.
Interior of this hospital
gets a solid four
'cause they actually labeled stuff,
the signs are legit.
The outside's a solid
seven and a half, eight.
But it looks more like a
prison than anything else.
I'm over it.
I'm building my own hospital.
If you get this video to 100,000 likes.
For now I want you to
watch this memes video
'cause I guarantee you
it's gonna make you
laugh or your money back.
And if this doesn't make you laugh,
this Onion reviewing article video thing
will make you laugh even more.
As always, stay happy and healthy.
(peaceful music)